no jaywalking on my watch Baton Rouge
Louisiana local sheriff's department is
back peddling after its officers falsely
arrested at least a dozen gay men for
quote crimes against nature an
undercover deputy headed to a park
looking for gay men while his partners
from East Baton Rouge Parish Sheriff's
Department hid nearby to record any
exchanges the deputy struck up a
conversation with a 65 year old man he
saw in a parked car about you immediate
get after denying being a cop he asked
the man if he had any condoms and then
suggested they go back to his pack for
some drinks and some fun got a nice
apartment hot pockets the whole shebang
when they arrived at the apartment the
deputy slapped cuffs on the senior
citizen sorry grandpa these aren't the
fuzzy kind the sheriff denies targeting
gays saying his deputies are just trying
to protect children from leave acts I'm
Sheriff Sid Gautreaux asking you to be
safe but the man who got busted didn't
agree to have sex in public and he
wasn't even engaged in prostitution
because money wasn't involved how about
we engaged in consensual affects and I
arrest you so how did the department
justify the arrest deal well by invoking
an anti sodomy law the kind the Supreme
Court declared unconstitutional ten
years ago tell it to the judge the DA
didn't press charges because no crime
had been committed in fact this is just
the latest in at least a dozen similar
arrests dating back to 2011 according to
the Advocate of Baton Rouge makes you
wonder how long all of this would have
gone on had it not been for the
newspapers investigation but come on no
cops had better things to do Baton Rouge
suffers from the nation's eighth highest
murder rate and homicide has increased
40% from the decade ago so yeah it might
be more dangerous but maybe deputies
could spend less time busting gay men
and more time busting murderers follow
the show on Twitter submit your nominees
for next month and check out Johnny Owen
this month's featured follower is the
big shot with Twitter in me are you
twittering me